- [Interviewer] All right, Damian.
- Yes sir.
- [Interviewer] Damian.
So nice to see you this morning.
- Good to see you too.
- [Interviewer] Saw you strolling
by with your shopping cart
full of recycling stuff.
- [Damian] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And you told
me some very interesting news.
- [Damian] Yeah. Yeah. I'm
going on four months clean now.
- [Interviewer] So you kicked fentanyl?
- Yep. And heroin too.
Yeah. Oh, I got the great
help of these though.
I got to put these out,
just to let the world know
that these are available to
them free all day, you know?
And they help tremendously.
- [Interviewer] What are these?
- Suboxone.
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah. Well, I guess...
So you are using Suboxone?
- Yeah.
I kicked cold turkey for it
to resonate and stick with me.
You know, the horribleness of it.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
- But then afterwards,
cause I have all these prosthetic parts,
I took that just for
pain reliever, you know?
And also it acts as a, almost
like an inhibitor you know
from me doing more dope
because if I was to do dope,
whether fentanyl or heroin,
it just wouldn't get me high at all.
- [Interviewer] Okay so I thought
when you told me you went cold turkey,
I just figured you went
cold turkey and quit
and that was it. But
you're using Suboxone,
which I guess is very helpful, right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
A lot of people do.
- I use the Suboxone
for my prosthetic knee,
metal hand, metal jaw,
metal eye socket, back problem and stuff.
- [Interviewer] How's it feel
to be clean from fentanyl?
- Good.
- [Interviewer] Yeah?
- I noticed I got quite a
lot of time on my hands.
(Damian laughs)
Now that I'm not doing
the 24/7 dope search, you know?
- [Interviewer] Right.
- Like, you know,
I don't have to hustle for dope money,
I don't have to go and find the dope man
once I get the dope money, you know.
That consumed pretty much all...
- [Interviewer] How many
years were you using?
- Altogether like 25 years.
- [Interviewer] 25 years.
And how old are you now?
- 43.
- [Interviewer] 43.
You've been clean four months?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's a
lot. That's enough time
to like be able to look back
at that period of your life.
Like what are your thoughts
on that period of addiction?
- I don't enjoy looking
back on it, you know?
Cause I mean, it's like all
the stuff that I did to get it.
I mean I wouldn't do it.
Other people do, you know,
sell themselves and I don't steal.
But I mean I gotta dig through
trash cans for recycling
or I was a panhandling, holding a sign.
And that of itself is
horrible. You know what I mean?
You get these people driving
by just cursing you out,
telling you to get a job.
And they got all of these
great smart ass ways of like...
- [Interviewer] As if you don't
have enough shame already.
- Yeah. Socking it to you, you know?
They're like, "Hey, come here
bro. I got something for you.
You hungry?"
I'm like, "Yeah."
They're like, "Come here, hurry up bro.
Light's going to change."
I'll go hobble over. And they're like,
"Here you go bro. Don't
spend it all on one place."
Give me two pennies.
- [Interviewer] Really?
- I'm like,
"I guess it's better
than nothing. Thank you."
And they're like "Ah
ha ha." Like, you know,
they just had the greatest
laugh of their life, you know,
for totally disgracing somebody
and making them feel like crap.
- [Interviewer] No, I think,
I think this little world,
this addiction world,
is very misunderstood by a lot of people.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So where
are you staying now?
- In a tent.
- [Interviewer] You're in a tent?
But you're not using, you're
surrounded by drug addicts.
- Yeah. Everywhere.
- [Interviewer] Suboxone is...
What are the ups and downs of Suboxone?
- The ups.
It helps keep me off of dope, you know
because I know that it's
not gonna have any effect.
If I wanted to do dope, I'd
have to stay clean off of it
for at least five days, you know?
And by then the itch would be way gone.
But then I'm going to slowly
start weaning myself off.
I'm not planning on staying on that
for an extended period of time.
- [Interviewer] And that's legal?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Could
you, if you wanted to,
get a full-time job
and on Suboxone?
- If I got an ID, yeah.
Yeah.
- It's classified as a
narcotic but I would think,
well, I don't know actually.
I'm not really sure.
I mean, I hear that people
have and they do work on it,
but truthfully I'm not 100% sure.
You know? Cause I mean it says,
don't operate heavy machinery.
- [Interviewer] No, but
if you need to get a job
at a grocery store or something like that,
you could do that?
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Is that in
the cards for you? You think?
- Once I get my ID. But that's
not so much in the cards
as in me getting my own business started
with the Sober Living Home.
- [Interviewer] Oh really?
So tell me what you are going to do.
- Well, I'm waiting to get my stimulus
so that I can travel to Arizona,
where I used to stay for a little bit.
And I'm gonna cash out
all my 401ks out there.
Through Macy's, Dillard's,
Texaco, Chevron,
Make Modeling Year, Shasta
pools, Whitewater pools,
a couple other places.
- [Interviewer] Then
start a sober living thing
to help others?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- And then I'd like to
expand to a rehab if I could.
But that is going to take
me a little bit of time.
I researched it and I have to
attend school to be certified
to be a substance abuse counselor.
And then from there then
I could open up a rehab.
- [Interviewer] Good for you.
- Oh yeah.
I figured I'd have the
like edge on helping people
seeing as how I've been through it all.
- [Interviewer] Oh I
think you can help others.
And I bet you it would help your whole.
The way you view yourself
by helping other people.
- Yeah. I mean, I'm slowly like
viewing myself a little bit
better than I was, you know?
- [Interviewer] No, I can sense that,
when you first walked up, I'm like,
"Wow, that's Damian."
(interviewer laughs)
- Tremendously lost weight but
I mean, I'll get that back.
- [Interviewer] Yeah,
you're always lean anyway.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] But now
I can see it in your face
and the way you speak and
your eyes and everything,
you seem a little clearer and healthier.
- Yeah. I mean I feel a lot better.
- [Interviewer] So tell me about
what it's like to go cold
turkey off of heroin or...
- Oh fentanyl. Ooh, horrible.
I mean, it's like worse
than heroin and longer too,
you know?
- [Interviewer] First off,
what's the difference
between heroin and fentanyl?
You've done both right?
- Yeah. As far as in the high?
- [Interviewer] No, I guess
the high and the addiction
and the...
- And the
addiction withdrawals?
Okay. Well the high,
heroin is not as strong.
But when I initially started it,
it hit me pretty, pretty good.
But with me, my chemistry
is like a little mixed up.
So I would get hyper for the most part.
And when I do heroin, I'd
be out and about, you know,
just all over the place.
And just to put it into perspective,
when I was doing speed, methamphetamines,
I get tired and I go to sleep.
- [Interviewer] Yeah.
I think all these drugs
affect each person differently.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] For most people
I think meth keeps them up right?
- Yeah. But then like I've
been running into people though
such as myself, that it gets
them like tired, you know?
Cause our chemistry, I
think cause I'm ADHD.
- [Interviewer] Yeah. I
think that's got a lot
to do with it.
- Yeah.
And fentanyl, when
fentanyl hit the stage...
Yeah wow, it was a
different world you know.
I didn't have to shoot up
and I could take like one
or two hits of this stuff.
You know, when I first started mind you.
And I'd be lit, you know.
Like I would be like, at first
I'd be like just comatose.
Like how I would normally
be off of heroin.
But then once my body got, I
guess acclimated to it all,
I started to get the energy
and hyper off of it too.
Like I'd see people and it frustrated me,
cause I'd see somebody.
I'd smoke with them.
I'd give them one hit,
next thing I know I'm
having to give them Narcan,
I'm having to breathe for them
cause they're dying in front of me.
- [Interviewer] Fentanyl
is a very dangerous drug.
- Yeah very dangerous.
And so I'm like, "Okay."
I revive them and I'm like thinking,
"Cool this is gonna
get me high as hell to.
One hit just put this dude out.
And he does as much as I do."
I'd take like 30 or 40 hits
and get nowhere near what
that person got, you know?
And I'm like, it was kind
of frustrating, you know?
Yeah. Cause I mean, my
body, it's something else.
I mean, to say the very
least it's very strong.
I mean, it's gotten me
this far so far, you know.
And I mean I'm blessed, but it
uses substances differently.
Like once I initially do it,
after that first time it's like,
body's like already saying like,
"All right, you're going
to have to up the dose.
You're going to have to
do a heck of a lot more.
Get some stronger shit you know."
(Damian laughs)
- [Interviewer] With fentanyl?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] That's incredible.
- [Interviewer] I've never heard that.
- Yeah. I'd be using like just a lot
in comparison to everybody else.
- [Interviewer] And so tell
me about going cold turkey.
- Oh yeah. So I did cold
turkey on the heroin.
That was horrible.
Stomach upset, diarrhea,
throwing up, cold sweats.
Fentanyl is pretty much the
same, only more intense.
- [Interviewer] And how
long does this go on?
- It took me like two, three weeks.
Like solid two or three weeks, you know,
of like just feeling like shit you know.
- [Interviewer] I've heard it described by
a lot of heroin or fentanyl addicts
that dying is preferable.
- Yeah. Like I was sitting there
and I would like be
saying out loud, you know,
"Why can't you just kill me,
God? I don't want to be alive."
And I was meaning every bit of it too
because I mean when every
single cell in your body
is screaming out in pain
and just saying "Stop this."
And I mean, wow, it's something else.
And then all the previous
pain that I have normally,
gets magnified like 100 fold.
So it's like, I could get
like a paper cut and just,
I mean if I was dope sick you know,
I'd be on the ground balling
pretty much, you know.
Like, "Ah this paper cuts killing me."
And it was like, it would really feel like
it was that horrible, you know?
So quite a doozy though.
Quite a ride I'll tell you.
- [Interviewer] Well, I'm excited
that you're considering a sober living
or your rehab thing for others.
- I mean it's something that
I think is gonna help me
to stick with the proper path, you know?
- [Interviewer] I can
totally see you doing
something great with your life.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] Of all the
people I've interviewed,
you're one of the
handful that I really see
like he has potential
to do something great.
- I appreciate that very much.
Stuff like that, you know,
really helps out a person's
psych and you know.
Especially when they're going through the
getting sober part, you know?
Cause I mean, I'm still, I
consider myself still a guppy.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, four
months is nothing right?
- Yeah I know.
I did heroin once, like quit cold turkey
and I stayed off of that
for almost nine years.
- [Interviewer] Nine years?
- Well, eight. A little over eight years.
- [Interviewer] That's great.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So you're
capable of doing great things
in your life. You just have to find a...
(interviewer laughs)
- Stick with it.
- [Interviewer] Stick with it
and get away from this neighborhood.
- Well I kind of want to stick around
so I could help a lot
of the people though.
But I don't want to stick
around, you know, like too much.
Just like be around.
- [Interviewer] You could
be like a, you know,
a mile or two off the...
- Yeah. Yeah. Definitely.
- [Interviewer] (inaudible) and probably
still get your job done.
- Yeah. Yeah. I'm still
waiting for housing.
I mean, there have been people
that I got set up with the housing people,
and they were set up like
two, three months after me,
and they've been in an SRO
like almost a year now.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I know.
- And I'm still sleeping on the streets.
And I'm like, "How does that work?"
I got you signed up months after me.
- The whole world is
upside down right now.
- Yeah and you're in an SRO and I'm not
and I'm trying to do
something with my life
and you're definitely not, you know.
It's like, do they like
have like a prerequisite
like you have to like
follow like to get housing?
All right. You gotta be a dope fiend,
you gotta be a scumbag, thieving,
piece of shit, you know?
And yeah, just be a horrible person
and we'll get you a place.
But, "Oh you're trying to
do something with your life?
Nah, you can sit out there and you know,
wilt away like the rest
of the flowers out there."
It's like what the fuck?
- [Interviewer] Well, you'd be a rarity.
I think there's not a lot of people
that have done what you're trying to do.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] So they're maybe,
from their perspective
you're just like nuts.
- True huh? I never
really thought about that.
- [Interviewer] Tell me about recycling.
How much will you get with like that?
- Oh for that, probably
like 10 or 15 bucks.
- [Interviewer] And then
you use that for what?
- Food.
- [Interviewer] Food.
And that's your whole existence basically?
- Oh yeah, right now.
And that 10-15 bucks took
me all day yesterday,
and then all last night,
and then this morning.
- [Interviewer] You walked down
the right block today then.
- Yeah definitely. I was so stoked to see
cause I wouldn't have
done it if this place,
this recycling place.
- [Interviewer] It's closed.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I don't
know why they closed.
- I know that, here's the thing they...
I'm blessed so, right now,
that they don't know how to
operate properly, you know?
Cause like every day, they're
supposed to be open at 8:30,
and yesterday they didn't
open until 9:30, you know?
And we're all standing out front like,
"What's going on?"
They're inside just like
dinking around doing nothing.
You know? It's like,
"Can we like, cause I'm
starving you know. What's up?"
"Oh, give us a minute. We
have to get everything ready."
"What do you mean get everything ready?
Y'all don't have to get nothing ready.
You have some empty trash cans
that we go in and we put our stuff into
and then you take the stuff we put in
and you dump it in a big container.
So what the, do you have to get ready?"
(Damian laughs)
- [Interviewer] But does living this life,
where you're going through garbage cans
to find plastic bottles and
cans and stuff like that,
and living on the street,
and this whole lifestyle,
it just makes you feel bad
about yourself and your...
- [Damian] A little bit yeah.
But at the same time I try and,
I've been trying to think
on a more positive level
that I'm doing what everybody
else out there isn't.
I'm recycling, I'm helping
the planet, you know?
I try and think about
that so much, you know.
But then you get somebody who comes along
and while I'm digging through the trash,
they'll throw their trash at me, you know.
And then start laughing about it.
And I'm like, "Wow, you could
have at least said excuse me,
or something. You didn't have
to throw it right at me."
- [Interviewer] You know what?
I would just plow through
this period of your life.
Get out of here, use it
to make yourself stronger.
- [Damian] Yeah.
- [Interviewer] I think you'll learn a lot
about human nature
and the way that people
function and operate.
- [Damian] A lot of isn't
quite an acquired taste
so to learn, you know.
Cause it's like, I don't
understand why a lot of people
do some of the horrible
things that they do.
- [Interviewer] It's a cruel
world. It's a cruel world.
But it's also a beautiful
world at the same time
It's both.
- [Damian] Yeah. I think...
- [Interviewer] You have to hang on to...
- [Damian] I think the human factor
makes it a cruel and ugly world.
- [Interviewer] Yeah but humans
can also be the most
inspiring and beautiful things
you've ever seen, both.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And we can be
the most disappointing
and cruel beings ever.
- The sad part is though,
to me it seems like the good people,
the people that inspire,
the people that help
and give love to others, you know?
They're decreasing in numbers.
- [Interviewer] Well
you're in the wrong part
of the world right now.
- I mean, self-centered LA.
(Damian laughs)
- [Interviewer] Although I would say
just this downtown skid
row area is probably...
- Oh yeah. Yeah.
- [Interviewer] You're surrounded
by snakes and vultures.
- Okay.
- [Interviewer] So you're not
gonna find a whole lot of...
- Yeah. They're thinking I'm the carcass
waiting to be picked clean, you know?
- [Interviewer] Yeah, yeah.
No and the fact that you're not using
makes you maybe a little
clear, more clear headed.
So, you know, you're seeing
the reality of what you're in.
- And I'm not getting taken
advantage of as easily.
Because before it would be like,
I'd be up for a couple of days you know.
And then I'd smoke some
fentanyl and I'd be out,
just out cold.
And people would come
and, friends mind you,
supposed friends though, and
they'd dig through my pockets.
Empty out my pockets while I was asleep.
And normally, you know,
if like a fly flew by me,
this is me on a sober
level, fly goes by me,
I'm waking up like "The fuck was that?"
But I mean, when I was on that stuff,
people are all like (indistinct).
"Hey, you want to give me a hand?
Let's take his pants off too
while we're at it. Fuck."
- [Interviewer] What's
the most horrific thing
you've experienced
when you were living on
the street as an addict?
- Oh, getting robbed
right across the street
while two police officers watched.
(interviewer laughs)
Dude had a gun to my head
and the other guy had a knife in my back.
And they stripped me down to my,
I had sweats on and a pair of shorts.
They took the sweats,
it was nighttime winter,
they took my sweaters and stuff.
I was left in my tank top, my
shorts, and no shoes or socks.
And they took all my money,
my phone, everything,
and all my clothes and
stuff, backpacked everything.
While the cops stood right
across the street and watched.
And then when all that was
done, I walk across the street
and I'm like, "What the fuck?"
And they're like, "What do
you mean what the fuck?"
I was like, "You guys stood there
and watched me get robbed for everything.
And you stood there and watched."
They're like, "Oh, they're robbing you?
Oh, we figured it was just
friends fucking with you."
I'm like, "Okay, did you not see the gun
to the side of my head?"
He obviously couldn't see the
knife in my back, you know,
but I mean really? What the
fuck are y'all here for?
I mean, you know, what good are you doing
if you're not helping
somebody who's getting robbed
right in front of you?"
They're like, they make a joke about it.
They're like, "Oh what? Let me guess.
How much did you get
robbed for? $1,000,000?"
(Damian impersonates police laughing)
And I'm like, "No, it was like 64 bucks,
and my phone, and everything
that I need to survive.
It wasn't $1,000,000 but
on that note, not funny."
I was like "Not fucking funny at all."
And as I'm sitting
there telling them that,
they're turning around and
they're walking away from me.
Like just cold shoulder.
- [Interviewer] The skid row?
- Yeah. This is right in
front of Macy's actually.
- [Interviewer] Oh, downtown?
- Yeah.
They were posted up
right in front of Macy's
and I was directly across the street.
- [Interviewer] Right.
All right Damian, well
great seeing you again.
- Yeah, you too.
- [Interviewer] I'm really pleased to see
your situations improving.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] Really proud of you.
- Thank you very much. I appreciate that.
- [Interviewer] I hope
all kinds of great things
come your way.
- Yeah. Me too. And you as well, you know?
Cause I mean you help out a lot of people.
And I mean, I just wanted to say that...
- [Interviewer] No. No. No.
I'm an exploitive bastard, racist.
(Interviewer and Damian laugh)
- Hey, you're none of
that, you know. You're...
- [Interviewer] Depends
on which comment you read
on my channel.
- Oh, is it?
- [Interviewer] Oh yeah.
- You're a genuinely
nice guy. Racist my ass.
You know? I mean you have
like every kind of person
that's working for, helping you.
(inaudible)
- [Interviewer] I think social media
is just a circus of...
- Yeah.
Whatever they can try...
- [Interviewer] You develop a thick skin.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] It's kind of
like being in the skid row,
you develop a thick skin.
- Yeah. But I don't
want it to get too thick
to where I just turn out
like a lot of them out there.
Just someone says, "Hi, how are you?"
And you're just like, "Ugh."
- [Interviewer] No, I don't
see that happening to you.
I can see great things for you man.
- Thank you.
- [Interviewer] I'm
proud of you, all right?
- I'm keeping it up, you know?
- [Interviewer] Excellent, good job.
- [Damian] I appreciate
that very much you know.
- [Interviewer] Oh dude, you're inspiring.
- [Damian] Thank you. God bless.
You're inspiring. You helped me out
mentally like big time, you know.
- [Interviewer] The positive
stories that I get down here.